[Music]
hmm as an opportunity to stand back and
ask ourselves what we mean when we talk
about intelligence and I guess there are
a couple of reasons to think about this
we operate now in a cultural moment
where there are sort of hyped up
versions of what we mean when we talk
about intelligence and obviously we're
all here because of one of those
versions which is of course machine
intelligence and a AI and I think it's
incumbent on us to ask ourselves what
we're actually dealing with when we're
talking about machines that operate in
some realm of if you like artificial
intelligence the other probably more
practical reason is of course if we get
the answer to this wrong people won't
use the things that you build and there
are numerous reasons numerous examples
that we see all over the place of
intelligence being embedded in various
software and hardware devices that we
use and people just switching it off and
really that's a problem that I feel like
we face and Microsoft and the research
group that I work in it's confronting AI
and thinking when will people actually
want to use something that introduces
some kind of interpretation and I think
that's a genuine question that we need
to ask ourselves so Rebecca had three
principles I'm going to talk about three
stories three if you like versions if
you will of what I see to be
intelligence or what I will go on to
talk about capability or capacity in
practice and this idea of capability is
really important to me what I feel like
we're dealing with when we talk about
intelligence is how the world makes us
capable how things in the world how what
we do in the world enables us to be
capable capable agents capable actors
and what I hope to talk about through my
three stories is how people are being
made capable in practice so
my first story is about and now
obviously there are different ways in
which we might talk about these examples
but I want to talk about vision in this
case and I'm going to talk about some
fieldwork that I've done with a number
of people in my group around
interventional radiology and some of you
may know interventional radiology is a
new form of radiology in which thanks to
various things like keyhole surgery and
new forms of instruments that allow
cameras to be placed in bodies surgeons
can now combine the scanning of the body
with surgery so prior to this most of
the scanning would happen pre surgery
and surgeons would would look through
the imagery and then operate on the body
what you'll see in this video it's I
think it's a two-minute video or
three-minute video is a surgeon
directing a radiologist to continually
update an x-ray and later on I don't
think it's in this video they go and
look at these MRI scans that are on the
LCD panels in the back of the room what
I want you to pay attention to is how
the surgeon is getting to see the body
if you will how vision is if you will is
enacted in practice and I'll talk
through this in a bit more detail but
let's watch the video
[Music]
trying to think
he's involved in and through the
collaboration with other people in the
surgery it's through that very tactile
sense of inserting a cable into a body
and feeling it not respond in the way
he's expected so in this case what does
something doing is he doing operations
of huge two vertebrae together that have
because of an injury the patient's been
subjected to he's inserting a wire into
one of the vertebrae to create a thread
that he will then tap some screws so
then he can join these two vertebra
together through some screws but what
he's finding is again through this
tactile sensation of the wire not
gripping into the bone the bone is in
fact is soft softer than he would have
expected and what they go on to do as
I've said is to these pre-op scans and
look at them again and think is there
some suggestion here that the bone might
be soft and it turns out that it is and
that in fact unfortunately the patient
has a cancer but it's only through those
activities through the sequence of
activities and the sensation of the wire
in the bone through the collaboration
with these people in surgery through
looking again at the sequence of x-rays
and then at the pre-op scans that that
discovery was made it wasn't made by
looking at the pre-op scans by
themselves and this is what I mean about
being made capable as it were the
surgeon here is being made capable
through this interactional sequence of
events let me just do another video
again let me turn to my second story and
again there are many things to kind of
ponder on here in this example but I
want to sort of think about how speech
is being used because obviously that's
one of the things that we think about
with machine learning and machine
intelligence this is a video taken from
a workshop that two of us attended in
which we're observing some pea
or preparing to teach blind children
various sports activities and in this
case they're practicing an activity that
they'll do with the blind children of
throwing and catching it's important to
know that Warren here on the right has
no central vision and very limited
peripheral vision and James is his guide
and they're gonna have a go at throwing
and catching I should also say that off
screen there's another couple I'm
throwing and catching and and that's
that the noise that's coming from from
that side off screen we're going to
different ways that we can modify we can
change things to make it appropriate for
the people that are in your group so
first of all sending simply means making
the ball go away from you and receiving
simply means Gavilan the ball and again
so that could be a throw in a catch it
could be a kick and a stop it's up to
your timing so when you just get with
your partner and work out how you're
going to send and receive this which
either
[Music]
and just to say that eventually phone
catch and go on to do it continuously to
the point where James eventually
dropkicks it and sorry what James
dropkicks in Warren catches it so what
we might imagine to be something that a
blind person would find incredibly hard
to accomplish turns out to be something
that they do from the second try onwards
now I've asked you to think about the
speech that's going on there and I'm not
sure I mean I've watched this video
again and again this is sort of one of
the things that I do as a sociologist is
really pay attention to the
interactional sequences that occur in
events like this so I'm not sure if you
will have noticed it but what's
happening while they're throwing and
catching as they begin to throw and
catch and again you may have observed
this is they don't just start throwing
and catching they just hand the ball to
each other they tap the ball in
preparation and it to the next person to
James Hunt Warren hunts it to James
James taps it hands it back to Warren so
there's this building up of a sequence
of actions almost in preparation for the
throwing and catching and the talk
happens in synchrony with that passing
the ball and so it's as though the talk
is preparing the throw and the catcher
for what will then be eventually the
throw and the catch I don't think that's
a coincidence
I think a lot of work is being done here
interactional e to help Warren C seeing
here is not a purely visual or
physiological activity it's an
interactional one see the seeing that
Warren does is something accomplished
through the tap on the ball through the
passing of the ball and of sequence of
interactions and through language being
sat on top of those activities and we so
when we talk about natural language
processing
it's problematic to extricated if you
will from the activities that are
unfolding and this is a this is an area
of machine learning that I'm deeply
involved in now sort of working with
people in natural language processing to
think more carefully about how we if you
like ground the data that we have of of
torque so the last story that I wanted
to work through is this is a slightly
longer video it's a video from a while
back in which we recorded people in cars
just to do I'd better understand how
domestic life extends beyond the
boundaries of the home and in this class
I'm just going to play the video because
it sort of speaks for itself it's a it's
I think it's real four-minute video so
it's quite a long one but bear bear with
it oops
on the carpet or anywhere
Oh Wilma carpet yeah he wouldn't find
his this is little couple indigenous
foods and reason I don't think they'll
be a no no they have they have like cats
do the whole train that's cats dogs
Oh what dogs still go to outside need to
pick it up in a plastic bag
well if we did
honey you can't even clean out the house
steadily you're gonna manage to see that
a dog
just say yeah yeah that would be nice
and and in the night time remember sleep
just come up and cuddle me and lick me
cause that's what my dog is to do not
know their dad is a senator game and the
morning to go it's a jump all over you
go oh go away you put the covers over
your head like you do when I go in no no
he would console me everything cuz he
was really sorry
coming out to cuddle to you though they
wouldn't they get all excited looking
when they see you and they lick you
oh just no anyway they nibble a new lick
you they're probably already bed as well
so say we when they get excited
[Music]
so what I should have said is this is
the school run which probably gathered
and they do this Chloe and her mother do
this every day so of course they know
the route
Chloe's well aware of the geography and
the sequence of events and Chloe's
timing here is perfect that last
statement why can't we get a dog is
timed not to get an answer because this
is a war of attrition this is something
in which Chloe doesn't want the answer
now she wants to wear her mother down to
the point where eventually she might
just say yes and of course it starts off
with if and ends up with why can't we
and if you like as an example of someone
and being entirely responsive to a
context to a spatial and temporal flow
of a car moving moving through a city
Eunice an organization of streets of if
you like a learning context Chloe is the
ultimate incarnation of intelligence
here but what I want to suggest is that
it's not Chloe alone of course it's that
car moving through a set of streets it's
Chloe's recognition and our various
points along that Street that builds up
this ability for her to reach this
crescendo of why can't we get a dog and
know that she's not going to get an
answer for it yet that the intelligence
there is something that is sort of made
able through Chloe's movements through
space and this is what I want us to
think about when we talk about
intelligence is there conditions that
are made possible through a set of
interactions through a set of
interactions without between ourselves
and in physical and temporal space that
we live in this sort of fantasy of
imagining that we might go from
something like solving go with AI to
replicating
the brain and yet what we don't really
understand is what are the conditions
that go is making possible because
they're not the same as what we would
use the brain for in all possible
context what are the very conditions
that go enables us to do in fact go it's
probably one of those few activities
that we act more like a machine than we
do like a human so it's not surprising
in a way that we that AI can solve that
problem and not solve Chloe's problem of
talking like a human in a car um I am
out of time I was going to talk to a an
example of how this might be applied to
natural language processing so if anyone
wants to talk more about something of
that context please come and see me
later
[Applause]